[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy monday no sane
american approves of what russia has
done in ukraine we certainly don't and
we don't know anyone who does
on twitter you see democrats pretending
that their political opponents are
responsible for the invasion and somehow
support it so joe biden and his staff so
mismanaged the world that vladimir putin
invades ukraine after biden told us for
months he could prevent that from
happening and yet all of it
is your fault so that's a slanderous lie
in this country virtually everyone
understands that the invasion of ukraine
is bad it's bad for us and for the world
and vladimir putin is bad too
so effectively in america those are
settled facts
we can stop debating them the question
is what do we do next vladimir putin's
badness doesn't absolve us of our
responsibility to think clearly about
how to protect this country and the rest
of the free world in that order
in fact putin's badness makes wise
decision making in the united states
more important than ever and yet at the
same time it makes wise decision making
harder to achieve it's not easy to see
the long view when you're angry
a writer called tanner green wrote a
piece this morning which you should read
it's entitled pausing at the precipice
greer began by pointing out that russia
has obviously earned our contempt most
americans now despise vladimir putin
that's understandable they're outraged
but moral outrage is not enough moral
outrage is not a foreign policy in fact
greer writes moral outrage can be
counterproductive it's clarifying but
here's the downside quote a righteous
reaction may be a dangerous one in the
field of power politics it is outcomes
not intentions that matter most
failure to slow down and examine the
assumptions and motivations behind our
choices may lead to decisions that feel
right in the moment but fail to
safeguard our interests secure our
values or reduce the human toll of war
in the long run
exactly
nicely put another way to express it
would be this our leaders could easily
turn this tragic and volatile moment
into an historic disaster they've done
it before
as of tonight here the two main things
we ought to be worried about going
forward
first and most obviously this war could
get much worse than it already is we
could see many americans die
joe biden is telling us he will not
commit american troops to ukraine biden
also claimed he opposed vaccine mandates
so is he telling the truth
even if he is telling the truth about
his intentions in this case biden can't
see the future biden has no idea what
will happen tomorrow or next week much
less next year nobody does
we do know that already many in
washington are pushing for a hot war
with nuclear-armed russia they're
demanding a no-fly zone over ukraine
that means american forces would shoot
down russian jets in ukrainian airspace
and also take out radar installations
and other facilities within russia
itself
not surprisingly the ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky is on board with this
why wouldn't he be he's asked joe biden
for an american enforced no-fly zone but
as we said many in congress are for it
too here's adam kinzinger
i think this is time where we need to at
the invitation of ukraine declare
ukraine a no-fly zone enforced by nato
in the united states we certainly have
the capability to do that the airspace
is still contested by the ukrainians we
could certainly shut down russian air
operations even if we don't directly
engage russian troops on the ground
we can shut down russian air operations
even if we don't directly engage russian
troops on the ground so that's a lie
it's hard to overstate how dishonest
kinzinger's claim is shooting down
russian planes and taking out radar
installations would by definition entail
engaging russian troops
if vladimir putin is even half as evil
and crazy as they tell us he is and he
may be
that could easily spiral into nuclear
conflict
so you would only suggest that if you
had nothing to lose and adam kinziger of
course doesn't his political career is
over he's disgraced he has literally
nothing to lose but many of us have a
lot to lose our country we have children
so we should pause before we do that but
no pausing aloud adam kinzinger thinks
you're a traitor if you're worried about
where this might go quote this
breathlessness over nukes is
mind-blowing kinzinger wrote over the
weekend nothing bad will happen
and maybe nothing bad will happen but
something very bad could happen and it
could happen fast
adults know that anyone with experience
knows that watch any war in history
and yet tonight amazingly some of those
adults and they are adults
favor this anyway
two former supreme allied commanders of
nato wes clark and philip breedlove are
pushing for armed confrontation with the
russian military in an interview with
foreign policy magazine breedlove was
honest enough to acknowledge that a
no-fly zone would amount to quote an act
of war and it would thank you for saying
so out loud but breedlove said he's for
it anyway
okay
so this is the moment when a functioning
news media would step in and start to
ask basic questions about what happens
next where with russia fine
what does that mean exactly how far is
the united states and its population who
would fight that war prepared to take
this conflict and to what end
once we start bombing russia will putin
withdraw his forces from ukraine
what will be left of ukraine by that
point how are we sure that putin who we
say is deranged won't go nuclear if a
war with him begins and then among many
other questions what will china's role
in this war be
thanks to the efforts of the biden white
house china is now vladimir putin's
strongest ally the chinese have decided
a long-term energy deal with russia they
now have skin in the game russia will be
powering china's economy going forward
good job biden white house but because
that's true how sure we that the chinese
will stay out of a war
how do we know they won't take down our
digital infrastructure which they seem
to some great extent to control in this
country etc etc you can think of many
questions but reporters aren't asking
any of them asking questions is now
immoral
richard engel who knows better he's the
chief foreign correspondent at nbc is
now demanding that american troops fight
the russian army it's a moral imperative
quote a massive russian convoy is about
30 miles from kiev the u.s nato could
likely destroy it but that would be
direct involvement against russia and
risk everything does the west watch in
silence as it rolls and of course the
answer is implied we can't watch in
silence that would be immoral if you're
a good person you will support a war
that could very easily turn into a
nuclear conflict
again this is moral blackmail no one in
america
takes pride at the site feels anything
but revulsion at the site of russian
troops within ukraine it's wrong it's
destabilizing to the world it is in fact
against our values
but how we respond is the question
thoughtfully has to be the answer unless
we're prepared to risk massive
consequences now richard haas who's the
president of the council on foreign
relations would under normal
circumstances be exactly the man you
would go to for a wise and reasoned
perspective on what to do next that's
his job
whatever you think of the council on
foreign relations and we don't think
much they're not a radical organization
their job is to think through the
consequences of action
but not anymore richard haas is four
square in favor of a hot war with russia
he's calling for quote regime change in
moscow because no doubt they'll greet us
as liberators what could go wrong
here's richard haas we need now a
responsive necessity to his war of
choice and there's got to be to raise
the economic costs at home to raise the
military costs on the ground i hate to
be so blunt but he you know the most
vulnerable thing that that putin's
vulnerable to is dead russian soldiers
so we have to make sure ukraine has the
means to to to resist
when did a guy that irresponsible take
over the council on foreign relations
and of course that's not his real job
the council on foreign relations his
real job is being a cable news pundit
and that's kind of the problem with the
level of discourse around this war the
problem is that when real people with
jobs that
convey actual authority start talking
like cable news guests things could go
sideways very fast dead russian soldiers
so it's hardly a defense of vladimir
putin to point out once again that a
shooting war with russia could have
massive consequences
for us
because it's not just russian soldiers
who would die americans would die too
potentially many of them
and by the way it's not all certain we
would win that war sorry it's not ask
anyone who's familiar with the current
state of readiness the u.s military
is victory a foregone conclusion
is this the the roll into baghdad no
it's not
this is not saddam hussein we're talking
about
so again the point is are we ready for
all of this
we're moving down a path that could
result in the destruction of the united
states
americans may be mad at putin
understandably but they're wary of where
our leaders are taking this next a new
cnn poll for example shows a strong
majority of americans speaking of
democracy opposes direct military action
against russia are they all traitors are
they all pro-putin
probably not
at the very least they would like and we
could use a sober national conversation
about the potential consequences of
where people like richard haas are
taking us now
that's the opposite of what we're
getting instead we're getting buffoons
like adam kinzinger sitting in his
office making bellicose noises on social
media just the other day kinzinger
posted images on twitter of ukrainian
air ace called the ghost of kiev he
downed russian migs left and right
well turns out the whole thing was a
hoax but of course adam kinziger had no
idea because he knows nothing quote the
ghost of kiev has a name and he has
absolutely owned the russian air force
he tweeted imagine a sitting member of
congress tweeting about a war like it's
a cable news site he absolutely owned
the russian air force really
get some respect people are dying
buffoon
kinzinger then attached an obviously
photoshopped image of the comedian sam
hyde sitting in the cockpit of a fighter
jet sam hyde for the record is not
ukrainian fighter ace he is once again a
comedian
that was adam kinsenger these are the
people pushing us toward a new world war
so at the very least let's pause and
think this through that seems fair and
as we do that it is also worth
considering what's happening here in the
united states concurrent with this war
and justified by this war and by that we
are speaking of the assault on civil
liberties now underway
it would be ironic if a defense of
democracy on the other side of the world
led to an erosion of democracy here and
yet that seems to be where we're heading
you'll notice that the moment that
russian troops rolled across the border
into ukraine democrats wasted no time in
attacking not just putin but there are
political opponents in this country
what did they have to do with it isn't
war the moment for unity we're all in
this together but they leverage this war
and the human suffering that inevitably
entails
to make partisan points
one msnbc regular in one of the stranger
moments you'll see on television msnbc
has had a lot of those recently said the
whole conflict was the result of a plot
engineered by vladimir putin's mole who
happened to be the former president of
the united states
trump was installed as the president of
the united states in order to weaken the
alliances that were preventing putin
from achieving his goals alliances like
nato our relationship with our european
partners our relationship with ukraine
trump was put in as a bulldozer
okay so we spent maybe three years
holding up
the lunacy of the russiagate people and
the lying
as evidence that maybe they shouldn't
have a meaningful effect on our national
conversation about politics and yet
somehow
through a very unfortunate confluence of
events those very same unbalanced people
are now having a measurable effect on
our foreign policy and if you think
we're overstating the lunacy try to
follow the logic here this is what she
just told us so donald trump that would
be putin's man in the white house tells
europe not to become dependent upon
russian oil as he did and to pay more
for their own military defense which he
also did and was scoffed at by the way
and yet for some reason putin then waits
to invade ukraine until his man in the
white house is gone and playing golf in
florida and now it is donald trump's
fault that europe is dependent on russia
for energy was all part of putin's plan
republicans wanted this to happen all
along you can imagine msnbc viewers the
one who sat through years of this
nodding along yes
now the p tape makes sense
what's scary about this is that it's not
confined to msnbc the overlap between
msnbc guests shouting nonsensical
partisan talking points and true
conspiracy theories and democratic
policymakers is profound
so democratic lawmakers are now
pretending there is a large and
dangerous fifth column in the united
states working for vladimir putin which
there is not
and as always they're talking about
themselves eric swalwell for example
recently took the maximum possible
campaign donation from a lobbyist for
nordstream to a g now that's the company
making the pipeline that will give
russia greater control over europe's
energy grid and from which the russian
government profits
so
eric swawwell is taking money from the
russians and by the way this is a guy
who had sex with a chinese spy has he
had sex with russian spies we don't know
but you'll notice the one guy who
probably shouldn't be calling other
people traitors as he takes money from
russian energy interests
is whipping around and accusing everyone
else of rooting for the russians watch
we have republicans who are rooting for
russia and that makes it very hard for
president biden to get the whole country
to go along when donald trump mike
pompeo and tucker carlson are rooting
for russians and that's being replayed
on russia tv to rally russians for this
cause
you know it's such an awful thing to say
we hesitated even to play that it's very
common you hear it every day
the question is why are they saying that
it doesn't make sense
but it makes political sense it is an
effort to cover their own tracts our
foreign policy establishment failed to
constrain vladimir putin to bring you
back to ancient history like a week ago
they were telling us that sanctions and
arming the ukrainian military would
prevent a russian invasion now they were
wrong about that they've been wrong many
times most recently in afghanistan and
in fact now that we're casting blame if
there was any single american who
deserves scorn and yes blame for the
invasion of ukraine it would be joe
biden
of course
it was his job self-described job to
prevent it
but of course they won't admit that
instead they're attacking you and
they're doing it with partisan goals in
mind democrats plan to use the ukraine
invasion this has become very obvious in
the last three days in the very same way
they used january 6th
so bad event takes place no one really
is for it no one defended the riot on
january 6th we certainly didn't
but history is rewritten immediately for
partisan ends so then you take the
hysteria gende up over that event some
of it legitimate by the way people have
a right to be upset
and you use that to purge the country of
the democratic party's political
opponents so what do they really hate
well listen to them they hate populist
politics
they hate populist politics in this
country far more than they hate vladimir
putin
so they're using this opportunity this
war in eastern europe to shut down
domestic dissent in the united states
and you're seeing it as always in our
allies first several of them including
canada have banned journalists who don't
agree with their view of the war
again if we're going to protect
democracy that should start at home and
democracy is defined literally defined
by the tolerance of the regime for
dissent
but no dissent is allowed
so they've pulled rt off the airwaves in
canada we did that long ago and that led
mother jones magazine to ask this
question today quote both rt and sputnik
air the united states too untrue but
whatever they don't know will biden
follow suit and crack down on pro-russia
disinformation if he does u.s cable
companies will also need to scrutinize
media outlets like fox news who shows
tucker carlson in particular have
parroted pro-russia talking points okay
so putin invades ukraine self-evidently
a tragedy bad for the united states and
we're using that as a justification
because we care so much about democracy
to shut down
any news organization any journalist who
questions
the democratic party
okay how do we get here anyway how
corroded have these people become
that they're calling for government
censorship of dissent and telling us
they're defenders of democracy that's
just the beginning anyone supports voter
id laws is a kremlin agent too you see
how they're going to use this here's
nancy pelosi and barbara lee to explain
we talked about the fact that the
invasion of the assault on ukraine was
an assault on democracy
barbara took the uh
time to talk about assaults on our
democracy in our own country the fight
for democracy
is taking place throughout the world
it's not only in ukraine but it's in our
own country and we've seen this through
the campaigns of misinformation and
disinformation we see this happening in
ukraine the
fact that now we see those at times to
take away the voting rights of people of
color of
americans of young people of seniors of
the disabled
you know it's not even worth parsing the
logic of something like that you can
only feel deep sadness that the people
you just saw represent you in our
legislature but by the way as long as
we're punishing people who are allied
with hostile foreign interests just to
restate the obvious china
is now russia's strongest ally in this
war and that has real implications for
people like i don't know nancy pelosi
whose family has gotten rich from china
or the entire american finance sector
same or hollywood or all the people are
now profiting from vladimir putin's
closest ally
will they divest of those investments
we'll see
but in the meantime you should be very
aware that there are partisan forces
trying to use the war in ukraine to
accomplish political
objectives here domestically and gain
more power for themselves it's not about
voting rights or shutting down fox news
it's about shutting you up personally
your ability to express yourself and if
you doubt that
you should know that senator mark warner
of virginia just wrote a letter to his
donors the tech monopolies demanding
that they quote restrict the spread of
russian propaganda he did not define
their term russian propaganda and as a
show that has been accused of
disseminating it repeatedly
we can tell you a little sensitive on
the topic and you should be too
so warner when on television recently
report that his donors from big tech
quickly complied with his demand watch
you sent letters on friday to
our leading social media companies
uh meta which runs facebook alphabet
reddit
asking them to take action to prevent
russian state media russian propaganda
operations from appearing on their
platforms i want to ask have you
received any responses yet to your
request that they take that action
well david
the short answer is yes virtually every
one of these platforms
has taken down some of the russian
activity or demonetized so they're not
making money off of rt or russian ads
on
real time during the platforms that's
good i commend these these platforms
so contrast that clip with the one from
msnbc we just played the first is when
dumb people do propaganda and tell you
that russia invading ukraine is somehow
about racism in the american south or
something i mean it's nonsensical what
you just saw is what happens when smart
people do propaganda the cia shill on
the left
the intel committee chairman on the
right
you'll notice that the cia shill said
russian state media or russian
propaganda just be completely clear
warner is not talking about banning
russian state media
he's talking about banning russian
propaganda a term that he gets to define
he's talking about censoring the
opinions of americans now to be clear
that is not allowed in a democracy
in a democracy citizens who rule have an
absolute right to have any opinion they
want period that's not an ancillary
freedom that's such some like random
thing that we have as a an added bonus
as americans
that freedom of speech freedom of
conscience is the central freedom we
have
it's the whole point of the country and
there is no point in supporting ukraine
if our leaders ignore our own bill of
rights
and we should demand that they respect
our bill of rights before they take a
single step forward in defense of any
other democracy period hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else